welcome back to cbs this morning
an exclusive cbs news investigation
reveals
many doctors who cause their patients
harm are not facing
discipline and some appear to be repeat
offenders according to national
statistics less than 2 percent of
doctors
account for more than half of all
malpractice payments
meaning a small number of physicians are
responsible for a big
problem for our year-long investigation
shot just before the pandemic
jim axelrod went to indiana to examine
what many in the field told us state
medical boards
are protecting doctors instead of
patients
i'd never seen that much activity in a
room after a surgery
something medically just wasn't right
jeremy payne is describing spinal
surgery
his 46 year old mother regina bruce had
in 2008
after she'd been rear-ended in a car
accident at the same hospital
dawn bell's father thomas cox went in
for a spinal fusion
during the procedure dawn told us the
surgeon had a problem
during the surgery he got sick who got
sick
doctor swayback were you and your mom
looking at each other like what is going
on here yes
we're like this are you serious both
operations were conducted by an
orthopedic surgeon dr
stevens fabric the surgeries left jeremy
payne's mother with her left leg
paralyzed
and dawn's father with nerve damage and
he proceeded probably to have seven more
surgeries
trying to correct the nerve damage what
is your
feeling as your mom
and your dad aren't quite right after
surgery
you're second guessing what's just
happened thomas cox and regina bruce
both reached medical malpractice
settlements with dr svabek
neither fully recovered both turned to
opioids to manage their pain
and later died it's pretty bad that
people can get away with what they have
in these situations
people doctors doctors are licensed by
state medical boards panels made up
almost entirely of fellow physicians
we spoke with more than a hundred
malpractice lawyers spread out over
all 50 states and heard the same thing
over and over medical boards do a good
job weeding out doctors who have broken
the law
but when it comes to malpractice when
doctors
injure their patients medical boards
often
look the other way we dug through state
and court records and found that dr
svabek lost his surgical privileges
at two indianapolis hospitals after his
practice fell below the standard of care
and concerns were raised about his
honesty and truthfulness
svabek lied about losing privileges to
the indiana medical board
then there are the malpractice suits dr
swabek has settled five suits
over more than a decade the most of any
orthopedic surgeon in indiana
in the last 20 years i don't know if
you're aware of this or not
had no idea are there dangerous doctors
practicing medicine
in indiana absolutely tina bell
is an attorney in indianapolis she's
been involved in cases against dr svabek
but agreements in court keep her from
discussing him
we have almost like this cloud of
secrecy
around the medical profession is it
possible to get into trouble
and still maintain your licensing
absolutely absolutely
bell has worked both sides of the street
she's spent more than a decade
representing hospitals and insurance
companies
before moving to represent patients as a
malpractice attorney
is the medical board protecting patients
or protecting doctors i would say
protecting doctors
you're telling me a doctor can make a
mistake
three four five times and it doesn't
affect their license
those are the doctors that worry me and
those are not the doctors that i'm
seeing
getting reprimands from the medical
licensing board so there is
a gap where some they're falling through
the cracks somehow here in indiana
we wrote to dr zwabek asking for an
interview but never heard back
my name is andy bassem a producer for
cbs news so our producer found him where
he's now practicing
in florida we don't really have any
comments to make about any of these
questions no
you had a disciplinary action here in
florida about operating on a wrong hip
that we saw
no is it it's not true that's not true
we got our information from the
department of health where records show
that since relocating to florida
dr svabek has been sanctioned three
times
including for operating on a patient's
right hip instead of his left
his penalty a fine of seventy five
hundred dollars
as you might imagine we had a bunch of
questions for the indiana medical board
after declining our request for an
interview we caught up with the doctor
who serves as the chairman of that board
you'll want to see that tomorrow morning
and we'll look forward to showing it
sure
jim yeah that's a great piece jim any
advice for people who want to check out
their own doctor ahead of a surgery to
know if there are any problems
yeah that's actually one of the central
points we get into tomorrow morning
how difficult that actually is all right
looking forward to that jim thank you
very well played jim when dr salbach
says to you i don't know where you got
your information you go well i'll tell
you exactly what
we got for the department of health
department of health it's very scary
stuff yeah
nice job all right